[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody for a
what hopes to be what promises to be
fascinating conversation with one of my
favorite thinkers and one of your
favorite thinkers whenever i ask who
should i get on the uh podcast again
it's always sabina haasenfelder in the
top one or two
most requested guests and she is our
guest today dr sabina hassenfelder
proprietor of the science without the
gobbledygook
empire all around the world joining us
today from germany how are you today my
friend
it's good to see you too this is twice
in a week we're recording this at the
end of july we were together for the
institute for art and ideas
uh live stream which you can find i'll
put a link to in the show notes below uh
and that was a lot of fun talking about
consciousness quantum mechanics the
observer all sorts of fun things but
that's only a small fraction of both
today's conversation
and the wonderful new book that brings
sabine back and that is called
existential physics
and it is a phenomenal book that i read
in hard copy i read it in uh kindle form
and your publisher was kind enough to
send me the audio version which is read
by a wonderful narrator uh gina i think
her name is anyway she's wonderful the
english version at least i hope you do
the german version uh sabina what uh i
love to do recently since you've been on
the show four times uh but i've only
recently started to make this a patented
trademark segment of the show i always
begin by asking the authors who come on
the show the meaning the interpretation
of the title of the book of the cover
design of the book and especially of the
subtitle of the book as well so i'm
wondering can you
do what we're never supposed to do and
judge this book by its cover well so i
have to admit that the title wasn't my
doing uh my suggestion for the title was
more than this
like
the song
um and it was supposed to say physics is
so much more than what we learned in
school you know balls rolling down
inclined planes and and resistors and
and all that kind of stuff
uh and this tied to like substantial
physics is what my editor came up with
uh he wanted to get the word physics uh
in the title and i thought he had he has
a point uh you know that people
know what it is about uh so i gave
ground on this but i insisted on my idea
for
the illustration which was a butterfly
fading away into some kind of particles
so i wanted to say
everything is made of particles like
this is what people always accuse
physicists of right you want to reduce
everything to the particles and that's
bad bad
and and so i i was trying to say it's
right everything is made of particles uh
but that's not the end of the story
there's so much more to it because
there's all this complexity and chaos
also coming out of it
um and this is why the butterfly it's
it's supposed to allude to the butterfly
effect
and of course your first book was called
lost in math and i kind of was thinking
about this book and maybe another title
if you publish with me someday uh would
be found in physics uh because i think
you know your first book kind of decried
the situation of of how you know physics
is being almost overarchingly taken over
by
this love of beauty and and symmetry and
and
organization and thanks to math and then
this is kind of yeah things are blowing
apart the butterfly's separating the the
chaotic nature which is closer to
reality uh of course uh and so yes and
the subtitle is a scientist guide to
life's biggest questions and the the
commonality between these two books your
two books
is that you're kind of a heroine in your
own story one of my episodes with you is
called the heroine's journey because you
go around the world in all your books
kind of like a journalist and i thought
we would start there
if you don't mind talking about how you
come to interview these phenomenal
scientists and and authors
zia morale mr roger penrose uh to david
deutsch et cetera um but the first
question you asked them sabina is very
it was very surprising to me you always
ask them if god plays a role in their
life why did you ask that i've asked
this question a lot of physicists and i
find it interesting that most of them
answer
so what would i ask them is are you
religious that's the way that i put it
um and they'll always say
no
but
and then after the but uh there's the
interesting part and this is what i
wanted to get to um the only person who
who didn't do this uh was david deutch
who was just like no
and zia morale of course she embraces
god she's not a scientist uh anymore she
did train at my alma mater brown
university uh for some time and i and i
do hope to have her on the podcast as
well but uh but she's a devout muslim
and she does practice uh as you say
you're coming off the interview with her
coming off of ramadan so i thought that
was interesting but actually you know
throughout the book the book has many
topics and it's interesting how much
physics has come full circle in other
words it used to be people like galileo
and and certainly uh newton and maybe
even einstein although we can get into
that had uh had this you know kind of
overarching
impact of religion on their life sabina
a lot of the conversations that revolve
around god unfortunately a lot of what
people end up saying is is basically
some kind of in my opinion warmed over
version of either i don't believe in it
or i'm agnostic you know which which i
used to leave open as as a question if
my audience uh if my guest would say
that uh for example my first guest
freeman dyson
on the podcast way back five years ago
four or five years ago he said i'm
agnostic but um but it's a great mystery
and i love doing and i said that's great
freeman but what do you do practically
how do you distinguish your daily life
from that of an atheist in other words
if a super intelligent alien looked at
you he would say you don't go to the
same church that that richard dawkins
doesn't go to
and so i'm wondering how do you react
when people uh do you ever have this
notion that they're not being either
intellectually honest or that they
really just don't want to come out and
say i'm an atheist or they don't want to
come out and say uh as stephen hawking
said you know that would cut book sales
you know in half more than adding
equations do you ever get the sense that
they're kind of modulating their their
uh belief or lack thereof in in a god or
in a religion to either sell books or or
for some other purpose well i would put
myself in into the same camp like i
would say that for what my research is
concerned i would say i'm agnostic this
is also what i write in the book like i
don't take sites uh i i don't know one
way or the other but if you're asking
about the way that i lead my personal
life um i i'm not religious i don't go
to church support practical purposes you
can call me an atheist
right so this is the way that people
think about atheists
um so i don't know how how other people
do it i i often get the sense that
scientists um
physicists which is the kind of
scientist that i mostly deal with they
kind of replace
this religious element that they've
taken out of their life
by some other kind of belief they could
be a multiverse or it could be the
beauty of natural laws
or whatever happening
yeah i get that a lot too in fact i did
a video for this you know they're mostly
a conservative um talking you know
network called prager university and i
did what's a bigger leap of faith god or
the multiverse and i i did it because
you know it's hard to reach you know
a predominantly christian audience you
know that it's conservative and teach
them about science and i wanted to do
that and two of the people i quote from
are you and paul davies but they
actually distilled one of your online
essays at back reaction your phenomenal
blog where i've been roasted at least
once i've been hosted multiple times but
i've been roasted once for my first book
we're not going to get into that
but um but we took an essay or they took
an essay and they distilled like from dr
sabina hassenfelder here's all these
commonalities between religion and the
belief in the multiverse and you're not
saying they are a belief in in a god but
there are certain similarities and and
yes you bring this up when you talk
about things like the simulation
hypothesis etc and um what do you make
of the fact that so many
scientists were religious even a hundred
years ago uh but uh and but now very few
i mean in the us 93 percent of the
national academy of science
does not believe or actively does not
profess a belief in god at least here i
don't know what it is like in germany or
europe but what do you make of this huge
i mean that's a huge phase transition
from almost 100 universal belief to
you know seven percent at best what do
you attribute that well um to be honest
i think it's a it's a mistake that the
traditional um
churches like the big churches make like
basically here almost all people are
either protestants or they're catholic
and they
hold on very closely to these very
traditional stories
which if you think about them too much
they don't really make a lot of sense
and
i think this is what put me off uh from
church so i actually went uh to church
for quite some time you know when i was
a teenager because i was interested in
it and i i liked the singing there was
free food
any kind of stuff and um to be honest
you know i i like the the social get
together which at the end of my book i
say that
science leaves at least leaves me
wanting in in that regard we could do
better when it comes to this to the
social aspect um but i think it's kind
of unnecessary like that there's key
elements uh to this belief
uh which i think people find attractive
and and it expresses something that they
uh that they care about uh which
doesn't hinge on the literal
interpretation of certain phrases in the
bible that kind of stuff
uh and so i i
i
think that what puts scientists of those
religions is that there are just certain
elements that they can't get themselves
to subscribe to
yeah
right they they want to believe that
everything they do is rational but i
don't think a person who did everything
rationally
uh would appear very rational in other
words i think we we all have irrational
beliefs and then some are more
irrational maybe than others and it's
kind of uh it almost provides an outlet
for people like we're going to combine
things yeah you know i was interviewed
recently and someone asked me like um
what do you want to discover with the
simon's observatory or what do you
believe did inflation occur or was there
a bounce and we're going to get into
those subjects in just a bit with you
because they feature prominently in
existential physics but um i said i
don't want to believe in anything like i
want to have evidence for something like
i said i always joke i don't believe in
gravity i don't have faith in gravity we
have evidence for gravity and one of the
consistent themes in your wonderful new
book is the power of a scientific idea
is
uh that from which you can make
calculations and and you can make
observations comport within the context
of that particular framework um and but
i'm wondering you know to push back with
respect as i always do you know there
are situations where people explain data
using models that are completely wrong
i'll point out uh kepler right kepler
used the otico's data uh and and other
observations and he made it beautifully
fit into this model of the solar system
that had that had i gotta put these in
here sabine because i bought these just
for our interviews so he had these
crystalline you know spheres and he had
orbs and he had pyramids and and all
sorts of cool things
and he got the right answers you know so
how do you react to that how do you
react to the fact that sometimes a
totally wrong idea can still be
consistent with data are we in danger of
being too beholden to the notion that
everything has to be you know
falsifiable and uh et cetera and and pop
aryan uh are we too in love with these
ideas um lately in terms of our
scientific well well you you say it's a
totally wrong idea but the only reason
we know this is that we got better data
and it didn't fit to it right i mean and
this is exactly how science is supposed
to work um yes so so this is all well
and fine i i'm not sure i um i i see the
problem there but i mean as you say it's
what i'm no
i think it's what i'm trying in my book
is i'm trying to
distinguish between what we actually
know what what we can read out of the
data and where we
supplement
what we actually know with belief which
isn't wrong but i think as scientists we
should we shouldn't
mix
the two things together
so you would say then that
the lack of evidence for a multiverse or
for a simulation hypothesis or
many of the myriad things that we can
get into that is provisional in other
words it could be the case that
that inflation took place or a big
bounce took place or there's a
multiverse but we just we have to wait
uh because we don't have enough data or
are there certain things you can say are
never going to be true no matter how
much evidence we collect
i wouldn't say this but when it comes to
stuff like the multiverse i can't even
think of any evidence
that could possibly
support the hypothesis so this is the
big problem that i have with it
um
so um on on a slightly more technical
level
the issue i have with many many of these
ideas is that they
make assumptions which are actually
unnecessary to describe anything we
observe like this this is the big the
big issue with the multiverse uh you can
say well there are those infinitely many
universes out there
but there's no way we can observe them
not not just that we can't see them
there's there's no possible measurement
that we can ever do
to
to
find evidence for their existence
then i would just say well it's not a
scientific idea
right um and so you're free to believe
in it if you want to it's fine if you
want to believe there are infinitely
many other universes and and there are
copies of you in many of them and they
they do whatever they want uh that's
fine but please don't pretend it's
science
so uh you also say in the book uh you
you make commentary on uh on some past
guests some upcoming guests but it seems
that uh that you know one of the biggest
targets for your ire and or at least
your your amusement or befuddlement is
is max tag mark and and those people of
of his his kind that that like to
promulgate the idea of what he calls the
mathematical universe uh which is not
only one multiverse as i understand it
there's at least four different kinds of
multiverses some of which i don't think
are
controversial in other words that he
says there are things we cannot see that
are outside of our horizon i don't think
you would disagree with that you might
say that that's not a multiverse but but
at any rate um why why do you say as you
do in the book uh you know that that
this you know kind of thing was probably
done to sell books
and and for that it was quite successful
why does that particular um
conjecture
uh annoy you as you say i don't think i
say this in the book i i i think i have
one sentence in which i mention uh max
which uh is something to the extent
i think he only came up with the idea of
the mathematical universe to prove that
it that he's a seriously weird fellow
which i think is appropriate given that
he calls himself uh mad max
right
and um so
you know don't get me wrong i i i really
love him uh he he's cool and uh i i it's
a very thought stimulating idea and i i
think generally this is why people like
the multiverse because they like
thinking about it and there's there's
nothing wrong with it but um it's it's a
philosophical idea that that all this
mathematics actually exists in some
sense it's not the scientific
idea
i don't think he came up with this
because he wanted to write a book and
sell the book
doesn't really make a lot of sense does
it
um
well yeah i mean i think yeah i i agree
he he's he has more integrity than that
kind of characterization but i would say
you know one thing that people push back
on when i where i have these debates is
well you know didn't so and so
demonstrate that you could see the
impact of a of a bubble collision in our
universe and isn't the you know the cmb
cold spot or couldn't there be other
anomalies our friend arvin ash is doing
a video uh this week on his wonderful
channel uh called the dark flow and it's
about possibly there's another universe
pulling our universe towards it and
that's right so there are people that
say no sabina you're wrong we can
falsify the the multiverse it might take
a couple of trillion years but it's in
principle falsifiable what do you say to
people that come up with ways to prove
or disprove the multiverse using
evidence for one thing as you probably
see i seen i address all those points in
the book and i've also a video coming up
which i already recorded in which i say
these are the typical points that
princesses always bring up to me like
the first point is usually you skipped
over this
brian which is black holes we can't see
inside a black hole then uh
yeah yeah uh the second one but they're
also um no one expects the universe to
end beyond the cosmic horizon then the
third one is what you just said well you
can actually see it and and and uh
there's a fourth one oh it's simple
that's the fourth one as we we can get
to this if you want to but so so the
thing with the
um
with the idea that you can actually
observe it i think this is what's called
a bait and switch tactic right first of
all first we're talking about this
general idea of the multiverse with
these infinitely many copies of you and
blah blah blah blah and then suddenly
you're talking about about a very
specific proposal of the multiverse uh
which uh maybe you know the one with the
entanglement i think this is the one
with the with the dark flow uh right or
and then that's the idea with the bubble
collisions and so on and look those
actually make predictions and that's a
slightly different problem um which is
that
physicists think that just because
something is falsifiable it's also good
science which i say where you've you've
misunderstood pretty much everything
about the basic philosophy of science
um but also i mean if you just look at
how it went with those predictions well
no one's found any of this evidence like
they've actually looked for it like the
these particular patterns i think uh
will will kinney wrote a paper about the
this idea with the dark flow
uh and
then the thing with the bubble
collisions i mean you know that they
haven't actually found the signature
right
right
right
and i think yes you're absolutely right
i mean people say
all falsifiability means it is science
but i can prove to you that my
astrologer yes i go to see an astrologer
you know she she made a prediction it
didn't come true therefore it must be
science right so
but one person you do call out by name
as is upcoming guest nick balstrom uh
who uh you say the simulation hypothesis
and i'm quoting annoys me
why does it annoy you how can how can a
scientific uh idea or philosophical idea
annoy you well if they would just use it
as a philosophical idea that'd be fine
with me but it has this they're trying
to give it this scientific flavor
right and
what it actually is the um
simulation hypothesis it's a statement
about the properties of the fundamental
laws of nature and that's something
which physicists deal with it's it's not
philosophy um and so if you if you
believe that you can actually encode
general relativity and the standard mode
of particle physics on a particular type
of computer
then you better tell me how you're going
to do this
and it's not a trivial problem uh like i
mean i i mentioned some examples like
especially when you're talking about
chaotic systems and that kind of stuff
it's not as simple as just saying well
you know if no one's looking into this
corner of the world i don't have to
compute it
that cheating right please please show
me your algorithm
and then and then show that it actually
reproduces our observations
and of course they don't do this like
they don't even get anywhere close and
this is why i say it annoys me now if
you want to talk about it on this
philosophical level like we we may all
be simulations or brainstorming that's
or whatever i'm like yeah
do what you want
yeah these are these are old questions
and i feel like we recapitulate all
these things every every 10 20 years it
said we have to re rewrite the
literature of what came before because
it's expanding at an exponential rate uh
and therefore uh you know i think it's
it it just behooves people to want to to
uh make a contribution to it and and
from there i want to turn to another
topic that i get a lot of questions
about a lot of my fans listening and
watching you um will want to know
something you don't really talk that
much about um you probably have a video
about it we'll get to your video uh
ovra and your catalog in in a bit but uh
and that's aliens uh which which are in
the news almost every day now uh ranging
from you know people like past guest tom
the long you know claiming he has uh
recovered uh you know
portions of an alien spaceship when he
came on my podcast uh which was quite uh
quite interesting to to go down the
rabbit hole with him and find out
actually he can't verify exactly that
he's owned it anyway uh but he is i give
him credit he brought a lot of this you
know he was a musician for this band
blink 182 he lives in san diego great
guy fun guy but you know he kind of got
this into the attention of the media
about five six years ago and now it's
risen all the way up to my friend and uh
and colleague and and president of the
simon's foundation uh professor david
spurgle and uh david is now co-leading
this nasa panel commissioned by the the
the chief administrator on down to
investigate the role of what they call a
uap's unidentified aerial phenomena but
that could include ufos objects it could
include evidence and data of course i've
had on avi loeb and and other people uh
as well but i wanna i haven't asked you
about this um where do you come down do
you do you believe that there are
uh you know credible uh bits of evidence
suggesting that earth well first of all
the aliens exist uh other life forms
exist let's start there do you think
life exists outside of the earth and is
that a scientific question or is it a
faith-based question well we don't
actually have any evidence that
life exists elsewhere so um at this
point i would say it's a faith-based
question um so if you want to know what
i believe i believe the answer is yes
um that's mostly because i i think that
it isn't as difficult to create complex
complexity um as physicists like to
think
uh i think businesses have somewhat of a
bias that everything is kind of simple
and then they think life is really
really difficult so it has to be rare in
some sense um
i i think that's not correct uh but of
course i don't know
now if you're asking about any
particular type of evidence i have to
admit i i haven't followed this at all
personally i haven't encountered any
particularly
you know convincing evidence
but
yeah i haven't really looked into it
now are you
in the camp or perhaps not in the camp
of those like our mutual friend eric
weinstein uh who suggest things such as
uh the fact that we should devote some
substantial resources to
the investigation of the phenomenon
because it might reveal new physics that
could then be used to solve many
predicaments that we have on earth
namely how do we get off the earth
without you know as he says you know
putting chemical oxidants inside of a
phallic shaped tube and shooting it to
mars as as our friend elon wants to do
uh but
would you say that if we did find
evidence of not not just alien life like
slime mold on you know on proxima
centauri b but if we found technological
intelligent life that that would open up
a new portal into physics that we would
otherwise be ignorant to do you think
that's even a conceivable uh prospect
for humanity well it's certainly
conceivable in in the sense that it's i
can't imagine it um
if the question is how likely is it i
have no idea i mean i agree that this is
something which we should investigate
now if if
i think what we said was we should
invest significant resources
because it brings up the question like
how significant right what amounts are
we talking about
and i'm not really in the position to
make that kind of judgment uh as i said
i haven't really followed it i would i
would generally agree yeah i mean it's a
really important thing it's one of those
things where the payoff could be so huge
that it would be stupid not to look at
it right
yeah i think that that's absolutely true
uh as well and yet you know the question
of the the level of um of fervor
about it is kind of unmatched by the
evidence and i want to run an argument
by you that i've used on other
scientists that are you know more
involved with this um
you know phenomena and even the the
concept of it uh and that's
this concept called panspermia which was
originally it sounds dirty but it's not
don't worry we won't get our youtube
demonetized uh but the uh the concept
was that life on earth it doesn't solve
the origin of life problem but it solves
the origin of life on earth problem and
that's by these little objects called
meteorites by the way you can get your
own meteorite if you subscribe to my
mailing list
briankeeting.comlist and if you
subscribe to sabine's mailing list maybe
she'll send you like a theory or she'll
she'll she'll tell you that you're full
of gobbledygook uh but you should
subscribe to that sabine hossenfelder
has a wonderful mailing list we'll put
links to that below
but um but the theory of panspermia
posits that life on earth originated
because uh objects like these meteorites
had chemical uh life
exist molecules or precursors to life or
even life itself and they can survive
and they can land on on the earth and
then that causes darwinian evolution to
sprout right so that's the theory but i
invert that argument and i say if that's
true then we should see life on uh on
europa or on titan or on some other moon
or asteroid or something because this
we've had life on earth for four billion
years uh it's it's only took a couple
hundred million years for life to get
kicked off and often earth gets hit by
meteor meteoroids and those blast off
these same chunks of earth including
life and they should be floating around
the solar system for literally billions
of years and some of them should have do
land on mars we know that they've landed
on mars because we have stuff from mars
that land on earth anyway sabine this is
a long-winded question but do you
believe that the lack of evidence of
life from earth on another body in our
solar system can provide some bayesian
prior on the existence or the ability
for panspermia to take place in other
words for life to get uh spread
throughout the cosmos as soon as it gets
created
but of course in principle yes exactly
don't have a terrible lot of evidence
about uh
you know my microbial life on other
planets like we've just about made it to
mars or maybe to the moon but what do we
know about the other planets and then
there's this whole issue about the
habitable zone right if you're only
looking at planets in the habitable zone
then this planet is it
right
um so
i'm not sure how useful this evidence is
um it's certainly evidence and you
should you should include it into your
priors uh but
you know it's totally outside my
research area
yeah okay well that that never stops me
uh from just wild speculation um
something that is in your uh research
area is of course cosmology quantum
cosmology
gravity early universe because in fact
that's how we met uh what is it 13 years
ago
my wife was pregnant and i think you had
just had or you were pregnant at the
same time we met in sweden you organized
this wonderful conference on quantum
gravity and observational evidence for
quantum gravity
often i hear in my field cosmic
microwave background uh
experiments polarization experiments
like the simon's observatory there's a
beach ball behind me you're watching on
my youtube channel dr brian keating or
sabine's
youtube channel which is science without
the gobbledygook
you uh we often talk about the
dispositive evidence that detection of b
mode polarization if truly primordial
and not from dust uh that that would be
pruvitive that inflation took place so i
want to ask you first of all
a question that you are such an expert
on which is quantum gravity if i say a
sabine i detected a radio wave today and
that's proof of there being photons you
know quanta of electromagnetism isn't
that the same as me saying i detected a
gravitational wave at the surface of
last scattering and therefore there must
have been quantum gravity from these
primordial polarization perturbations
aren't we kind of
putting too much evidence on as i hope
that we will discover something but
isn't it too much to say that that would
be evidence for quantum gravity to
detect classical sized perturbations at
the surface of last scattering
yes i i i think that would be too much
to say um
but i don't think that's what people are
saying right as he correctly said they
are claiming it's evidence for inflation
and of course in inflation the idea is
that you
you get those waves as a relic from the
quantum fluctuations and so forth but
from from the b modes themselves you
can't actually infer that this had to be
the case
and as you certainly know um you know
that there are particular types of
inflation where you would wouldn't be
able to detect them and then there are
other theories which are not in place
which actually make the same prediction
so you get this whole what's called the
inverse problem
um if you make
the observation can you actually figure
out what the correct theory was um but
having said that um
that there are other signatures that you
can look for in the cmb at least
theoretically that would actually allow
you to pin down that the original
fluctuations must have been quantum in
nature and can't have been classical
stochastic fluctuations and the people
have written papers about this like 10
years ago or something around the time
maybe that the workshop was stuff like
this
and uh it turns out that it's just
really really hard to measure so um the
current measurement precision just just
isn't there and it's probably not going
to be there within my lifetime
ah so i just turned on my computer light
system now that's great um so sabina
another theory that stands in contrast
to inflation are so-called bouncing
models or cyclical models and i want to
turn to that that's part of a wonderful
chapter in the book um and and i don't
like i never like to give away the book
you know i don't want to give away too
much except to say that you have to buy
it you have to buy it in as many formats
as i have it which is hard copy uh
digital ebook and audio copy uh so so
please sabina's twins need to go to
expensive school in america
anyway sabina you talk about uh these
alternatives and you say i quote the
bouncing model and the cyclic models are
quote worse than inflation so first of
all i want to ask you
can you define uh what these bouncing
models are you talk to one of the
foremost proponents of them sir roger
penrose nobel laureate in this book who
you presuppose actually this is amazing
sabine in the book written in 2020 2019
said i can't believe he hasn't won a
nobel prize and then he wins a nobel
prize in 2021 when the book is finished
anyway uh you uh he has i didn't just
write this most popular models called
the conformal
sorry okay did me to interrupt you i
didn't just write this for them i
actually wrote this on my blog
before you won the nobel prize
you don't have to take it on my word
well you're
sabina can you tell me what the
powerball lottery numbers are going to
be next week i'd i'd really like to know
for the to support the into the
impossible
so
yeah so he has this conformal cyclic
model he has these hawking points
i want to talk about this and also past
guest anna aegis
who has been on the show recently
talking about cyclic models
why do you say it's worse than inflation
is it like what winston churchill said
about democracy the worst form of
government except for all the others is
is it true that uh bouncing models are
really worse than inflation if so how
well
i i'm not sure i said that it's worse
than inflation but it's worse than um
lambda cdm like the what you could call
the standard big bang
model basically and i would say that
inflation is already
tacked onto this model right
um and so the reason why i say it's
worse is that
you're inventing a more complicated
story that comes
before the beginning basically um so so
so you're you're attacking all this
whole story about an earlier universe
which collapsed and then oh i mean if
you if you're with penrose and i mean
you you talk to him uh on your on your
channel
um
then he gives you the story about
supermassive black holes that radiate
and that leaves some kind of imprint in
the cosmic microwave background
in our universe uh and the obvious
question that you should ask like um why
don't you just start with an initial say
that had this imprint wouldn't this be
much simpler than inventing this
complicated story for how they came
about
and so i think that that all those
models are running into this problem at
some point that if you go back in time
the initial state becomes simpler and
simpler and simpler and if you want to
attach a more complicated story that
happened earlier there's no scientific
justification to do this
um
okay so on the bouncing model the
criticism that you actually say is that
the problem with these ideas is that
they have no explanatory power
they do not simplify the calculation of
any observations so
i don't know you know if you follow
closely the battle between you know
people like will kinney's and the and
the paul steinhardts and the and the
aegises but they do claim that they can
make all predictions with actually
simpler
observation they don't actually need
the inflitan they don't actually need to
instantiate a singularity and their
bounce is purely classical so yes they
need a pre-existing universe
but they don't need or they need some
space time at least but they don't need
a singularity where there is perhaps no
hope of computing
anything that that is on built on on
such a
shaky foundation so what do you say to
those new instantiations of that model
which suggests that you don't need a big
bang at all you just need uh you just
need this this slow collapse from a
previous uh universe it doesn't have to
be that that violent even
so first of all you just reappeared i
cannot see you again
so um i would i would like to correct
for reporters
you said that i'm claiming those models
don't have any exp planetary power it
that's not what i'm claiming i'm saying
they don't improve the explanatory power
of lambda cdm so they just
add unnecessary quality i was just
quoting from the book the problem with
these ideas
yeah i was just quoting the book
actually says that they have no
explanatory power but i understand
you're not making that strong acclaim
right now in other words
yeah right so so in
if you add them so this is what i
explain in the book right so you can
always add an earlier story and it's
this earlier story that has no
explanatory power you could as well just
take lambda cdm and be done with it and
that's in practice you know what
cosmologists do if they run their
simulations
you don't have to start with a
complicated story about this earlier
universe it doesn't actually aid any of
your
of your predictions and of course yeah i
mean those people would disagree they
would say well in some sense this is
actually simpler than inflation and um i
don't know maybe it is but as i said
earlier it's not that i'm a fan of
inflation
right to me it's just replacing one evil
with another evil we don't need either
so in terms of the uh competing
alternatives between the conformal
cyclic cosmology
uh the bouncing the pyrotic model uh
there are some alternatives from neil
turock who's upcoming guest on the into
the impossible podcast or actually by
this time it'll be a past guest because
that's coming out soon um so yeah i
guess the the comment that i would have
is how do i as an experimentalist what
do i do i mean what's nice about
inflation is that it's making
predictions um uh some would claim it
does
and that one of the most robust
predictions in fact the only one that is
you know intrinsically robust it seems
agreed upon by everybody including roger
and including paul and anna is that
there'd be these primordial
gravitational waves but as you said
the uh the amplitude of these waves is
incredibly sensitive to the actual
fourth power of the energy scale of
inflation therefore inflation could have
happened at a very very slightly lower
energy scale raised to the fourth power
anything gets very small and therefore
we wouldn't see it so it might be true
but
unfalsifiable or unprovable rather so
off of the alternatives what's nice
about them is that you could rule them
out right because you could observe
gravitational waves um which which would
in some sense or error bonds or whatever
roger talks about right so is there any
uh what at what point does the virtue of
being falsifiable enter into your
calculations as a as a theoretical
physicist does is that a virtue at all
of these alternatives to inflation that
they can be disproven well in principle
yes but in practice i don't i don't
think it's going to happen but because i
mean you know how theorists are if you
come if you come with your observation
and say well i've you know i've just
proved it
they're going to twitter something about
their model and then they they can make
it work
right this is what theorists do
so i'm i'm not buying it um there's too
much freedom in those models
so pivoting to
the unobservable multiverse now to the
collapse of the wave function uh my
final question before we get to audience
questions and and that is um
we talk a lot about uh what is knowable
in this book and actually the
conversation with roger penrose is not
about his conformal cosmology it's about
the measurement problem the orchestrated
um collapse uh he calls orc or
so i'm going to have him and stuart
hammer off his collaborator uh on the
podcast coming soon so stay tuned for
that uh and you quote from uh this
passage by uh bertrand russell that the
chicken is fed reliably every morning at
9am until one day the farmer chops off
its head more refined views as to the
uniformity of nature would have been
useful to the chicken i want to ask you
i was dreaming about you know what would
i ask sabine that she's never been asked
before
in this book you talk about your
favorite part of physics that does what
we call outreach and that's
the minimized action principle which
which i agree is pretty cool
but i want to ask you
i think the weirdest thing about physics
in my opinion quantum physics now we're
trying to collapse of the wave function
the chicken's head getting cut off um
i think what's most fascinates me is
that in classical physics we can form
commutation relations between position
and momentum and then and those can be
used to construct the action which can
then be minimized in your favorite three
but my favorite thing is by adding uh
just one number an imaginary number the
square root of negative one
we get in quantum mechanics that p and q
do not commute right um
isn't that really weird sabine how is it
that and and that's sort of the most
quantum of all quantum things is that
you can't you know measurements don't
commute um what what is this uh telling
us is this significant that in classical
mechanics the commutation relation
vanishes and in class quantum physics it
doesn't vanish and in fact it involves
the square root of negative one where
the heck does that come in this has
always really troubled me and i'm i'm
i'm curious what what do you make of
this strange behavior
am i just lost in math
no i'm i'm i'm with you i mean so
but i'm afraid i can't answer the
question so and i've always though maybe
i look at it from exactly the opposite
direction you know i as i've said a few
times i originally studied studied
mathematics not physics and i've always
found
complex numbers to make much more sense
than real numbers
which i i dare to say probably a lot of
mathematicians would have the same
aptitude
well well because in in the real numbers
you could you can't solve certain
equations right it's not complete so in
the complex numbers you have all this
stuff with the holomorphic functions
dare to say it's beautiful blah blah
blah
so to me the question is more like
why
do the observables
only take on real numbers like the
values why are they real numbers what
happened with the with the um complex
numbers or to put it differently why why
are all the
uh measurement operators permission
i have no idea
i i think it's an interesting question
where do all the ice go so it's
basically it's basically the the
opposite to your question right uh but i
don't know yeah very good question
and then i guess i would ask well
wouldn't you be more in love with the
quaternions and the clifford algebras
and i mean at what level does it stop um
you know that that it stops being
beautiful or interesting um okay well
we've reached the end of i only have one
more question and and that's um uh not
not a very uh personal question but i
want to ask um your youtube channel is
seen by half a million people uh on on
average on on video channels and i know
you do
make a nice income from it and and
that's wonderful but what is being on
youtube what does it give you besides
income or fame or attention what does it
fulfill for you why do you do it
besides the money as i said you know
that is important well
i i love science and uh i want to share
it with other people it's really it's
really pretty simple it also gives me an
excuse to learn a lot of new things i
mean as you've probably noticed it's
like half of the time i talk about
physics that i'm really familiar with
like the principle of least action i
recently made a video about this i have
one coming up on the multiverse i just
talked about the block universe so this
is the kind of stuff that i know where
i'm like okay i know it other people are
interested in it so i just shared with
them
but i also talk about stuff like uh
nuclear power like how green is it how
much do we have to worry about air
pollution and i have one coming up on
energy storage uh like how does it
change the carbon footprint what what do
we do if the sun doesn't shine the wind
doesn't blow that kind of question uh
and i just learn a lot from it and and
then it makes sense right so once i've
put in the effort i share it with other
people so they get something out of the
work that i
do yeah it's uh it is really delightful
it's one of the few that i you know have
a notification bell set for besides this
channel so you should all subscribe i'll
have a link to her channel down there um
or maybe up here
and uh and it's called science without
the gobbledygook and um it is delightful
i mean you talk literally talk about
everything places that i would never
fear to tread you talk about transgender
athletes uh which is a favorite uh
video uh that i was um i can't say i was
surprised that you made it but i was
glad that you made it it's very
interesting and provocative uh you did
one does two plus two equal five you
know question mark uh so you're not
afraid to tread into very interesting
waters and before we had uh started this
conversation on recording it you
mentioned that yeah sometimes you get
people that unsubscribe or that send you
you know email oh you should do this or
that how do you react you know as
someone who's you know aspiring to to
grow an audience the way that you have
how do you handle the naysayers the
haters the the the trolls and stuff how
do you do that um with and maintain i
mean you are known as a curmudgeon in
some ways or a contrarian uh but you're
actually very cheerful and and uh you
know and i love that about you but how
do you handle the naysayers you know
does it does it get it and it hurts you
in your heart at all
well you know what they say hey just
gonna hate um
i i think if you reach a certain level
of popularity
you have to expect that kind of thing
there'll always be people who will try
to put you down one way or the other um
and i think i've just been doing this
for too long to really be bothered by it
you know sometimes i do get things wrong
but i think i'm i'm like
i'm genuinely honestly trying to get it
right so for example the thing that when
i talk about trans athletes it was just
something that i
was wondering about like i was like what
are people talking about why is it so
controversial what does what does the
one side say what does the other side
say
and then as i as i just said i thought
well you know now now i've made the
effort and i kind of i think i roughly
understand what they're talking about
and those are the key points um let's
make a video about it because maybe
other people find it useful and i think
what do you see from from the amount of
people who watch the videos is that yes
there are a lot of other people who find
it useful and um so that's how i think
about it i i think i'm i'm being useful
that that's that's the bottom line
okay so now i'd like to ask you
some audience questions and then i have
my
patented uh questions that i call the
quintessential quattro the fantastic
four
which have been updated since the first
time you were on the show two or three
years ago okay first question
comes from audience member who has a
lovely name uh which i would uh
reconsidered for one of my kids uh and
that's his name is zero skull
and uh he says first of all remember
it's zabina
not
okay fine thank you zero skull but he
says i want to ask you sabine uh what
misconception about science do you see
most often from your audience
misconceptions about science or
scientists
either
he's asking about science but i'm
interested in either answer
um
i think in in the denialist camp you
get a lot of people who are like they're
just into it for the money
which i think is just ridiculous like if
you know any scientists right in
academia
money isn't the reason they're there
right exactly
um he also asked about do you read any
science fiction
um
not recently i i on occasion read some
kind of short story but recently i've
been more into
fantasy i've discovered there's a genre
called urban fantasy which i think is
pretty cool
so you know they're
werewolves in london and they kind of
stood up and i think it's awesome
okay
oh great um so a few more questions from
my youtube audience and then we got some
on twitter so reminder you can uh
subscribe to sabina's channel and then i
always take audience questions so i've
got an interview with roger penrose
coming up so leave your questions on my
channel uh for those folks i have an
interview with mutty milgram coming up
sabine which you'll be interested in we
talk about your some of your ideas and
in phase transitions and condensed
matter dark matter ideas super fluids
so there's another question that's
coming from
someone named scarlace
and scarleigh's here she says i love her
videos i have a question for her she has
repeatedly bashed theories like string
theory for being scientifically lacking
in their predictive power or provability
yet she believes in super determinism
how does she rationalize this position
well because super determinism does make
predictions
i mean like
i've given talks about this i've written
papers about it um the problem is that
the the experiments are not being done
so i'm trying to get people
um to actually do these experiments
um
i've i'm actually i'm always surprised
that people think i'm bashing strength
theory or that i'm highly skeptical
or something i actually think that
string theory
does have quite some merit you know it's
it's based on on on a good idea um and
it was trying to solve an actual problem
which is the missing quantization of
gravity
i think he kind of
went into the wrong direction
um
when when they were trying to
hard to make things work out and so on
and so forth so maybe if they have been
a little more intellectually honest
early on then it wouldn't have gone
downhills
quite as far but i mean there's some
interesting things that have come out of
it and the adcst stuff um is certainly
worthwhile um so that that's all fine
with me
[Music]
um so uh cisnad oh
sitos asked what do you think about the
free will theorem
uh and have you seen john conway's
lectures on it his philosophical
arguments i think if you look at it the
right way
free will theorem and super determinism
will turn out to be equivalent now i
always say sabine i believe
in free will
because i have no other choice but
uh what do you make about this uh free
will obviously it plays and i think that
the main answer is by the book because
she she covers that in great detail and
she has some videos on it
buy it listen to it in all three formats
um so maybe we'll move on to other
questions
um
here's a question the nothing channel
sabina is critical of the particle
physics field but is also against
building larger colliders i understand
her points but then how does she think
we go forward should we just give up on
particle physics until we get more clues
to guide us and how will we get those
clues thank you nothing channel
how can you be against future particle
accelerator and
it's not that i'm against particle
physics or something like this i i've
been um very specifically against
building this super expensive future
circular collider
because i just think it's too much money
for
too little benefit
um
now there are certainly interesting
things that you can still do in particle
physics uh it's not that i'm saying
let's let's throw out or particular
physicist
i'm not quite that uh bad but also i
mean i've i've extensively talked about
what we should do instead uh right i've
and i've literally written a whole book
about it um i'm i'm saying we should
focus on trying to resolve actual
inconsistencies
for example the missing quantization of
gravity is one of them and there's the
measurement problem there's also dark
matter um which um he just said
you'll be talking about uh with with uh
someone in general in the near future
um so which of course we're already
doing experiments about like for example
the web telescope right it is giving us
uh better data as we speak
and that's certainly something that we
will learn from it about about dark
matter so it's not like we're completely
stuck without putting this huge client
someone with a name i shouldn't
pronounce says will you ever have
another discussion or debate with
bernardo cashtroop who's an upcoming
guest on my podcast see i should
reference that you debated debate uh on
kurt j mungle my friend kurt j mungle's
theory of everything channel with
bernardo bernardo's coming up next week
so on my channel do you have any advice
for me or should i cancel the interview
well you know i i
like to think of myself as a fairly
open-minded
person so i wouldn't entirely rule it
out but i do feel like it was a mistake
because i was expecting a scientific
conversation and
it wasn't one i i had the impression he
didn't really know uh what i was talking
about to begin with and it it wasn't
fruitful and so i thought it was pretty
much a waste of time
do you have any questions that you'd
like me to ask him as a listener to the
in my conversation with him
no honestly
okay
uh
good okay so now we're gonna go to
twitter where sabine is prolific
and uh and and monumental
in her questions and answers and hot
takes on all topics um so her her uh
twitter handle is skdh
ask her paul simeon is asking ask her to
explain why statistical independence
in the bell inequality test is a
stand-in
for the desire of some physicist
to have libertarian free will now again
this is a major topic of the book but uh
but i would just say could you summarize
um uh that do these tests the xiling
your test the other thing do they have
any
have they influence you in any way or do
you think that there'd be
um you know basically no point in really
revisiting them
what's your take on on these bell
inequality tests designing your tests
and etc
so um i have no idea why statistical
independence was connected with free
will i don't know if you saw that
matt
met whatever his last name from pbs
space time
made a video about super determinism a
week ago or something and uh he he made
this pretty clear and i i think it's
entirely correct uh it it has nothing to
do with free will i think the way that
he put it which i thought was pretty
funny um philosophers have decided
exactly what they mean by if we will we
can talk about it again
and it's not going to happen right um so
it's i'm afraid it's one of those cases
where
physicists attached a certain label to a
mathematical assumption and people just
took it to mean too much
so um i i think we'd all be better off
if we wouldn't refer to statistical
independence as uh the free will
assumption or the free choice assumption
um great okay last question from the
audience on my twitter channel we have
many many more 50 150 questions across
all my platforms uh people we could go
all day
um
uh i think the the last one i'll ask is
um related to something that past guest
don hoffman said on my channel and
upcoming guest dr nima arkani ahmed
who's promised repeatedly to come on so
hopefully he'll make good on that i'm
going to see him next year in the uk so
i'm going to bring my my trusty recorder
with me and act like sabine on a journey
to understand these heroes but anyway
nema says that space time is doomed uh
what do you think of him actually let me
ask you a first question sabine i've
never understood this quote by uh your
countryman um albert here albert
einstein who said that
hereafter
space-time is doomed to never uh to the
the dustbin of history or something i
don't know he said something about that
uh he was wrong you know almost as many
times as he was right uh and it's too
bad because he could have had a good
career as i always say but but anyway um
what did he mean by spit like time
is doomed and space is doomed and only a
union of the two will survive what does
that mean is that just hyperbole and
then what is what are your thoughts on
nema's kind of echoing of the great um
of the great einstein
um okay so my history might fail me but
i think it was neinstein it was
minkowski uh because he introduced
mikowski space-time
and he made this statement about how
space and time
on their own are doomed to fade into
whatever i i can't actually quote it
um but of course it was einstein who
actually figured out what to do with it
right
so this is where where einstein comes
and now now what what what string theory
is or what nema i mean with this today
i believe they mean that space time is
emerging in some sense it it comes about
from something else
it's like an approximate description um
and there's some some underlying reality
and that may be um i'm quite sympathetic
to this idea um but i also don't think
that it necessarily has to be the case
it might just be that spacetime
ultimately is the fundamental thing
yes
so yes you're right minkowski said that
space and timer itself are doomed to
fade into mirror shadows um but einstein
uh
had some questions he said
time in other words is an illusion
uh people um the past and the um the
future of time
uh well
yeah anyway einstein said so many things
he's like uh uh like what what roger
penrose says about stephen hawking is
that you should always have made a bet
with him because he was either wrong or
eventually he'd flip his perspective and
you'd win the bet no matter what um and
we didn't get into black holes and
information i'm sorry we'll save that
for part five
so sabina we are now going to go into
the impossible with the
patented fantastic four
or quintessential cuatro existential
questions with sabina but to get access
to those existential questions you'll
need to subscribe to my newsletter which
is brianketing.com
list and also subscribe to sabina's
newsletter as well
links to those in the show notes below
and sabine i want to thank you uh for
everything you do uh around the world
inspiring literally millions of people
through your videos your books uh your
blog your newsletter all of which i
subscribe to and and you should too and
get this wonderful new book and her
first book lost in math it's a beautiful
uh a companion to these two uh anything
else you'd like to mention sabina that
you're like my viewers and listeners to
know about
no i mean um this is just wonderful love
talking to you i think you you have a
great channel uh with a lot of super
interesting interviews
thank you sabine that means the that
means the multiverse to me all right
i'll let you get on good knocked
donkey shane and i'll see you again soon
i hope
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
this
[Music]